letztes jahr habe ich versucht innerhalb
von einer woche poker spielen zu lernen
und dabei hat mich die begeisterung fürs
spiel gepackt als ich dann gefragt wurde
ob ich nächste woche lust hätte gegen
fedor holz einen der besten pokerspieler
der welt mit über 30 millionen dollar
wings zu spielen ist mir eine sache
sofort bewusst geworden
ich brauche training und da ist
gleichzeitig auf dem weg zur rolex etwas
still geworden ist schieben wir das
wieder perfect match in den nächsten
sieben tagen werde ich also jeden tag
vollzeit pokerspielen um mehr erfahrung
zu sammeln und um mir von dem gewinner
rolex finanzieren zu können wer alles im
turnier dabei ist was ich gelernt habe
und ob es für eine rolex gereicht hat
erfahrt ihr im video
[Musik]
ja
7 ja ja ja mal vorweg poker ist und
bleibt ein spiel mit glücksspiel
komponente wenn ihr also nicht 18 seid
dann lasst die finger davon wenn ihr 18
seid lasst auch die finger davon oder
spielt nur mit geld das ihr wirklich
verlieren könnte glücksspielsucht ist
ein großes thema man rutscht da
schneller ein als man gucken kann wenn
ihr probleme damit hat check den link in
der video beschreibungen dafür die hilfe
und weil das auch schon ein bisschen
verwirrung gesorgt hat wo stehen wir
eigentlich gerade im rolex trade up ich
habe alle schuhe verkauft bekommen den
macker die drei oder vier dank und den
jordan fiasko dadurch waren wir zu dem
zeitpunkt bei 2009 157 euro und 75 cent
dann habe ich aber 690 euro bei
sportwetten verloren und deswegen sind
bestand jetzt bei 2267 euro und 75 cent
und 1000 dollar oder 838 euro werde ich
jetzt diese woche poker spielen das war
das ein zahlungsmittel und ich glaube
dass wir mit 1000 dollar
ganz gut bedient sind als allererstes
habe ich meinen trainer angerufen der
mich auch schon beim ersten projekt
unterstützt hat da wirklich die 1000
dollar nicht sofort versenke und damit
ich auch wirklich was lernen weil es
soll wirklich ziel sein dass ich besser
werde und im besten fall mit rolex
verdiene oder zumindest mehr in die
richtung der rolex kommen als
allererstes habe ich nicht wieder
komplett ins poker thema eingearbeitet
im letzten jahr habe ich mich wirklich
dafür interessiert deswegen startet
nicht bei null ich habe im letzten jahr
immer mal wieder videos gesehen wo
irgendwelche profi hände profi turniere
analysiert wurden usw
deswegen war das jetzt nicht so ein
problem aber hat mir wirklich trocken
das leer macht ja gegeben bei dem ich
gelernt habe wie ich meine eigenen hände
bewährte wie ich herausfinden kann oder
einschätzen kann welche gegner welche
hände haben also wirklich einfach
objektiv poker gelernt dadurch dass das
spiel wahrscheinlichkeit komponente hat
wird das häufig von leuten einfach so
als glücksspiel abgestempelt so ist es
aber nicht man kann diese
wahrscheinlichkeit viel mehr für sich
nutzen um dem eigenen spiel einbauen
weil man einschätzen kann wie hoch die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass man die
beste hand hat oder dass andere leute
mit besserer hand ihr seht ihr jetzt im
hintergrund schon wie wir am tag 14
stunden gegründet haben vorher haben wir
uns allerdings gedanken gemacht was
wollen wir eigentlich spielen was wollen
wir erreichen
wie teilen wir uns die 1.000 dollar auf
also wie teuer dürfen die spiele sein
die wir spielen spielen wir turniere sit
and gos oder cash games spielen wir
texas hold'em omaha oder andere formen
von poker all das haben uns vorher schon
überlegt wollen wir satellite spielen
was quasi
eintrittskarte in teuren muss turnier
sein könnte oder machen wir so was nicht
all das was wir uns vorher überlegt
damit wir in roten fragen haben an denen
wir uns selber halten können im
endeffekt haben uns dafür entschieden
dass wir in dieser woche mindestens 50
turniere spielen wollen die ungefähr 50
dollar wert sein dürfen so dass wir
genau wenn wir quasi keinen cent gewinn
machen würden genau auf die 1000 dollar
kommen würden und am ende der woche auch
am siebten tag noch spielen können bevor
das video jetzt startet will ich noch
mal sagen dass ich jetzt nicht ins
detail gehen werde was unser bankroll
management oder unsere fertigen taktiken
angeht das würde den rahmen hier
sprengen und interessiert auch nur 0 1
prozent der leute die zuschauen wenn das
ein paar leute interessiert dann lass
mich das in den kommentaren wissen dann
macht man 2 kanal video dazu oder so an
tag eins an wenn das auch direkt so
umgesetzt und haben acht turniere
gespielt bei denen sich sehr sehr viele
leute angemeldet haben und dadurch auch
verhältnismäßig viele leute in der manie
kommen also einfach eine platzierung
erreichen die bezahlt ist
teilnehmerzahlen von 1.000 2.000 3.000
5.000 10.000 leuten sein wenn es ein
sehr großes turnier ist dadurch spielt
man einfach in der woche sehr sehr viele
hände und kann am meisten erfahrungen
sammeln wenn man dann mal in einem
turnier sehr sehr dick kommt also
einfach sehr sehr lange im turnier aus
hat und eine gute platzierung schafft
kann dieses eine turnier die verluste
von den turnieren davor vielleicht
wieder wettmachen und das war unser ziel
für die woche solche turniere spielen
und auf einen großen gewinn hoffen
unter allen bezahlten plätzen gibt es
dann natürlich noch mal riesige
unterschiede und die leute die es an den
final table schaffte verdienen
vielfaches von dem was leute verdienen
die jetzt einfach nur so knapp in der
manie kommen also dass da geht es dann
schon wirklich darum auf einen der top
plätze zu kommen das hat an tag 1 auf
jeden fall nicht besonders gut
funktioniert wir haben nach abzug des
bayerns also den preis den man zahlen
muss um im turnier reinzukommen 78
dollar verloren
davon sind wir bei ausgegangen und
tassen eben auf einen großen oder
vielleicht zwei große turnier-gewinner
diese woche und das ziel am ende der
woche soll die sunday million seien sehr
sehr großes turnier wo super viele leute
mitmachen und etwas über 100 dollar
brent kostet das war von vornherein so
eines unserer größten ziele der verlust
von tag 1 hat auf jeden fall stark
motiviert an tag 2 wieder durch zu
ziehen wir haben an tag 2 damit
gestartet die schlechtesten hände von
tag 1 uns nochmal anzuschauen oder auch
vielleicht gute hände
mein trainer hatte das alles vorbereitet
und hat wirklich das mit
trainiert und studiert und hat mir ein
paar wichtige tipps gegeben die ich am
tag zwei direkt umsetzen konnte um da
auch einfach wieder - zu machen wir
kommen zwar in einem turnier 25 dollar
reingewinn rausholen trotz alledem haben
wir weiterhin - gemacht und tag zwei
nach 16 turnieren mit 117 dollar im
minus beendet was wirklich ein bisschen
nervig in bar war aber okay weil wir
wussten dass wir ein größeres ziel am
und dass diese kleinen steps nach unten
möglicherweise in der wichtige lernphase
sind bevor wir dann in einem turnier in
sehr großem gewinn rausholen von
vornherein zu wissen dass das so
aussehen könnte hat auf jeden fall dabei
geholfen nicht so kraske demütig zu sein
nach dem zweiten tag 3 müssen wir nicht
drüber sprechen war absoluter träsch von
vorne bis hinten ich habe komplett rein
gesagt ich hatte zwar das gefühl besser
spielen zu können und besser zu wissen
die ich mit standard situation umgehe
hat aber nichts gebracht ich habe
komplett jedes turnier verloren dadurch
dass die turniere um 18 uhr es anfangen
und durch so viele teilnehmer
superlangen gehen können haben wir jede
nacht auch bis 2 oder 3 uhr getrennt
wenn es super schlecht lief wie am tag
drei damit vielleicht auch mal nur bis
zwölf oder 14 glich dann mit kombination
aus müde werden unkonzentrierter werden
und vielleicht auch nicht mehr dem
eigenen farben folgen ach ja falls ihr
euch fragt warum mein motorrad im
hintergrund steht ich produziere gerade
schon ein video mit city gemeinsam das
wird sehr sehr nice wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen wollten mich unterstützen
wollten dann vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren tag vier absolute horror tag
da habe ich gemerkt dass die glücksspiel
komponente wirklich nicht zu
unterschätzen ist wir haben mit sehr
guten händen sehr sehr viele turniere
verloren das war absoluter träsch
wirklich ich hatte dass alle meine
ergebnisse zu dem zeitpunkt schon in
excel tabelle eingetragen hatte also
genau vor augen wie es gerade um uns
steht wir standen nach tag 4 und
insgesamt da schon irgendwie über 20
spielstunden bei 768 dollar also sehr
sehr krasse - nach tag 4 also an dem
abend noch habe ich gemerkt das ist sehr
sehr wichtig für mich waren eine zweite
person dabei zu haben die mich daran
erinnert dass wir im plan haben und dass
wir uns weiter an den plan halten
wahrscheinlich wäre das dann so eine
situation gewesen wo ich jetzt ohne
trainer angefangen hätte viel mehr aus
dem bauch zu machen und es bringt nichts
wir haben uns weiter an dem plan
gehalten und das war sehr sehr wichtig
da eine zweite person dabei zu haben
dabei ist natürlich auch nicht
zuträglich die ganze zeit in die tournee
lobby zu gucken
zu sehen wie gut der erste zweite und
dritte platz geteilt werden und was man
mit dem geld wohl machen würde
das bringt überhaupt nichts und habe ich
dann nach tag 4 komplett abgestellt und
mich wirklich nur ausspielen
konzentriert tag 5 dann endlich die
erlösung die letzten tage schienen sich
ausgezahlt zu haben wir haben gut
gespielt wir haben gute karten und haben
es zum ersten mal an den final table
eines turniers geschafft in dem über 700
leute teilgenommen
das 22 dollar in lg halver turbo haben
wir auf platz vier beendet und ich hätte
eigentlich super zufrieden sein können
ich glaube wir haben über 500 dollar
rausgeholt in dem grafen sieht man es
auch wieder so einfach in die höhe
schießt ich war aber nicht zufrieden
weil ich nur daran gedacht habe was wohl
passiert wäre wenn ich diese hand anders
gespielt hatte dazu muss man auch wissen
dass wir die hand mit der er ausgeflogen
sind wirklich extrem schlecht gespielt
haben super untypisch eigentlich dass
wir so eine hand so gespielt haben
aber wir waren in der kritischen
situation dass wir irgendwas machen
mussten und haben uns da auf jeden fall
falsch entschieden das war eine hand
über die wir in den nächsten tagen noch
öfter gesprochen haben das war wirklich
absoluter reinfall und ist uns danach
auch so nicht mehr passiert aber die
motivation war wieder da man hat gemerkt
dass der plan vielleicht gar nicht so
scheiße war wie man gedacht hatte und
dass wir das eigentlich genau so geplant
hatten und es einfach sich nur über fünf
tage gezogen hat bis es dann auch
wirklich so passiert ist tag 6 läuft
solide wir haben bis dato schon über 42
stunden poker gespielt wir machen an dem
tag 35 dollar profit was nicht schlecht
ist aber auch nicht besonders gut auf
jeden fall ein ergebnis mit dem man
zufrieden sein kann weil wir kein minus
gemacht haben aber der große was nicht
der volle focus stammt danach tag 6 auf
den letzten tag mit der sunday million
naja ich hab im intro ja noch gesagt
dass ich erzähle wäre alles im poker
turnier dabei sein wird ich weiß nicht
genau wie das zustande gekommen ist aber
am freitag dem 12
also jetzt kommende woche freitag
spielen viel holz crispy rob re wie papa
platte 3 max unsympathisch ich und noch
irgendwelche anderen ich weiß nicht
genau wer noch dabei ist gegeneinander
poker ich bin absolut high ich freue
mich sehr gegen fehler holz zu spielen
und mir eine schöne klatsche von dem
abzuholen ist auf jeden fall ein
absoluter traum wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen wollte dann checkt den link in
der video beschreibung folgt schon mal
beitritt schreiben dann bekommt ihr das
auf jeden fall mit ich bin extrem gehalt
dann kamen das große finale
tag 7
wir haben uns für extrem viel geld in
turniere eingekauft über 400 dollar
haben wir an dem abend für bayerns
ausgegeben wir haben uns in mehrere 55
33 um 22 dollar turniere eingekauft also
wir haben richtig gespendet und haben
komplett offen sagt bekommen wir sind in
fast allen turnieren instant
rausgeflogen
bis auf in einem turnier dies eine
million werden uns für 109 dollar
eingekauft und zur mitte des turniers
enden merken wir das ist eigentlich
ziemlich gut läuft insgesamt haben sich
über 11.000 leute in dem turnier
angemeldet und nach ein paar stunden
merken wir dass wir sex ich gar nicht so
schlecht dastehen und wir eigentlich die
ganze zeit im oberen drittel mitspielen
aufgrund unseres verhältnismäßig großen
stacks haben uns dann dafür entschieden
paar mehr hände zu spielen und haben ein
bisschen mehr riskiert und deshalb
funktioniert wir waren auf einmal
unternehmen top 50 der noch 1000 leute
die in dem turnier drin waren was
absolut verrückt eigentlich läuft alles
ziemlich gut aber wir wirtschaften uns
immer weiter runter wir wissen aber
schon dass wir auf jeden fall ein
bisschen geld verdient haben und dass
das projekt auf jeden fall im plus ist
was uns auf jeden fall guten
seelenfrieden gegeben hat und wir
spielen weiter und alles läuft bestens
irgendwann war es dann so dass wir nur
noch ziemlich wenige big blinds hatten
ich glaube so circa 10 und 29 gefloppt
haben auf dem big blind was eigentlich
eine ganz gute position ist eine person
race auf zwei big blinds wir gehen
all-in und werden von zwei assen
komplettbox gewonnen haben die stars
nockberge 9
naja gegen aces was soll man da machen
442 dollar schmerzt bisschen wie immer
mit 100 107 70 dollar im plus wir haben
richtig krass gespielt das war echt das
war echt richtig gut
sehr schade trotz alledem über 400
dollar in dem turnier gewonnen was ein
absolutes highlight war im letzten
turnier im größten turnier der woche so
weit zu kommen hat eine menge spaß
gemacht ich hätte die neuen auch im
nachhinein noch mal so gespielt weil das
die andere personen es ist unglücklich
aber die 29 fand ich auf jeden fall ganz
okay gespielt insgesamt beende ich dann
das poker projekt mit 100 77 dollar im
plus womit ich absolut zufrieden bin ich
habe eine menge erfahrung aus dieser
woche mitnehmen können und freue mich
dass im besten fall am freitag gegen
clarholz und die anderen einsetzen zu
können ich bin gespannt wie hoch da der
können standard ist und wieder gespielt
wird wenn euch das video gefallen hat
lassen wir gerne ein leichter vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren in den
nächsten wochen geht es weiter mit
motorrad content und auch mit rolex
trade up sachen es hängt leider viele
sachen im zoll die ich für die nächsten
projekte brauche und die hängen auch
schon seit einem monat im zoll
es geht aber weiter ich habe coole
sachen geplant vergesst nicht den kanal
zu abonnieren
wir sehen uns